we know
they're all
lying is what really really makes me
just so sick of all of this let me let
me pull up this story we had another
story check this out you guys are going
to love it
southwest ceo says he never wanted a
covet vaccine mandate but biden forced
his hand
is that what biden is he's the patsy for
for the ceos for the establishment
they're like i'm imagining the ceo
sitting there and he's like he's trying
to do this vaccine mandate and like the
ceo from some other company like you
know aa is there and it's like
everybody's mad at me what do i do oh
just blame biden what do you mean you
don't blame but you're not blaming biden
for your problems oh biden's our fall
guy yeah all the problems in the economy
right now everything bad happening you
used to say biden did it okay and he
comes out and he's like i didn't want to
vaccinate medic biden made me do it even
though biden didn't make anyone do it
because there's no actual executive
order or or osha rule but it's a
convenient out for a guy who's who's
collapsing in his approval rating for
the southwest ceo to be like i don't
know everybody seems to be mad at the
guy
i'll let him take the fall for me i
think this is a continuation of the same
thing this is them wanting the
appearance of the thing without the
actual thing they want the appearance of
bowing to the superior you know having
some kind of responsibility to what
biden has told them to do even though
they haven't actually made a law or a
rule or even a mandate so they're just
taking the appearance they don't really
care about what's actually true look at
this let me read this they say uh quote
i've never been in favor of corporations
imposing that kind of mandate i'm not in
favor of that never have been but the
executive order from president biden
mandates all federal employees and then
all federal contractors which covers all
major airlines have to have a vaccine
mandate in place by december 8th so
we're working through that now that
sounds a bit circuitous there is the
federal employee mandate as my
understanding but this covers all the
airlines that's i didn't know that
southwest said last week that that's 56
000 employees need to be vaccinated by
by december 8th in order to keep working
for the airline under federal mandate
southwest announcement came a few days
after other carriers american airlines
alaskan airlines and jetblue informed
employees of the need to adhere to
federal vaccine rules in august before
the bond administration's action united
air airlines and hawaiian airlines
instituted coveted vaccine requirements
for their staffs united said earlier
this month that more than 96 percent of
its 67 000 us employees have shared
proof of vaccination after its late
september deadline what was the amount
of employees they had before this was
announced and also just to throw back to
what ian said
around august is when joe biden
announced the vaccine mandates and
that's when his approval rating flipped
the inflection point when all of a
sudden people were like i don't like
this guy because i'll tell you i
mentioned this on the show several times
i know somebody who is like
biden and waving biden flags and now
he's freaking out because he's like my
job is going to force me to do this and
i don't want to
yeah some people are saying that the
southwest ceo is in the world economic
forum is a part of that group and he's
it's also just very convenient to that
that he's just lumping everything on
biden he doesn't have to comply there's
a lot of other people there's a lot of
unions there's a lot of big companies
saying we're not going to comply with
this and there was even a statement
saying that southwest will not be using
the texas exemption as a way to
implement uh you know this vaccine
passport these vaccine
this vaccine mandate which they're
imposing there's also a very interesting
date that they're
setting not just with southwest but many
other corporations are setting the date
of december 8th as the deadline it's all
kind of done in unison which is oddly
strange as as well but again no one is
forcing southwest to do this it's an
executive order executive decrees are
argued they go to court there's a lot of
very important court battles so he's
moving forward with this and clearly a
lot of his employees a lot of the people
who work for him aren't happy with this
and they're protesting in their own kind
of unique way that we're seeing with
this freedom
i don't think it's protest
i i think kind of i think yes there's
there's there's a very kind of blurred
line here because the pilots don't want
to get officially in trouble i don't i
don't i don't i don't i don't i talk to
a pilot and he's like
it's worse than a sick out like this i a
lot of people want to believe that all
these pilots are like hey guys should we
jump ship right now and they'll high
five but don't let anyone know because
we'll get in trouble when in reality it
seems like yo
as we've been saying time and time again
you can only push people so far
i don't see evidence of an organized
effort i see regular people just saying
i'm out
and that's that's something
substantially worse it's like so this is
what i was saying the other day imagine
if biden came out and said in order for
everybody to keep their jobs they got to
go punch a baby
and then all of a sudden it's like
record resignations airlines shut down
what's happening it's like dude no one
organized an event not to punch babies
they just won't do it that's what people
need to understand about vaccine
mandates it's not like some guy called
his friend and said let's organize
together and refuse this it's a guy
being like yo i ain't doing that just on
there on his own he didn't need anybody
to tell him to do it
yeah that's fake um that along with
other uh disruptions in our supply
chains on our in our labor uh you know
workforce is something that's only going
to start from now on since of these
deadlines are just encroaching in just a
few days from now so
there's a big conflict happening and
whether it's organized or not organized
it's happening and there's a formidable
force of individuals of people saying
enough is enough i believe in my
personal autonomy i believe in my
personal liberty i believe in being able
to make the right decisions for myself
as a human being and the media is acting
like these people don't even exist they
do exist there's a lot of them there's a
lot more of them than we would even even
know about because they don't want you
knowing about this they don't want you
even talking about the major
demonstrations and protests that have
been happening all over the world in new
york in new york in italy in france in
australia in the united kingdom there's
been major huge rallies with thousands
of people hitting the streets saying hey
this is an unpopular uh
policy i don't want to ask permission to
go to the supermarket from the
government i don't want big fat
bureaucratic agents who work at the dmv
relegating every aspect of my existence
and what i could do and where i could go
i got i want to point something out too
the southwest ceo is really coming out
against the mandates
sounds like he knows what's really
driving the the work strength right
could i could i just ask you you said
that there actually isn't a mandate in
place
that so see the southwest ceo there's
not a real law there's so so biden said
if you got at least 100 employees you
got to mandate vaccines osha has yet to
implement any rule and there's no
executive order however what the
southwest ceo is saying is that joe
biden did issue an executive order on
federal contractors which includes
airlines therefore they must adhere to a
federal vaccine mandate now he's in
trouble though it's it's funny that the
media comes out and is like immediately
trying to debunk the narrative no no
pilots aren't aren't sticking out or
anything like that and i'm like okay
technically the truth but they're just
not showing up because they won't do
this now the ceo comes out and says uh
i'm i'm not in favor of vaccine mandates
well hold on there a minute who cares i
thought vaccine minutes had nothing to
do with why there was a major flight
cancellation and why you were
short-staffed yeah i thought it was
weather
he said it was the weather you know it's
funniest american airlines the only uh
airline impacted by weather it's amazing
they must fly paper airplanes that get
soggy and fall out of the sky that it's
it's complete bs they're lying for him
to come out and be like
i didn't want the vaccine mandate sounds
like he's now trying to placate the
people who aren't showing up
yeah and he's trying to shift blame on
himself his personal decisions and blame
it on biden which i think many
multinational corporations have been
doing many powerful interests have been
doing when they implement a lot of their
policies that they would never dare
publicly even speak about but when you
have a guy who's not really even there
who can't even speak properly that's the
perfect opportunity to ramp through your
bull crap blame everything on him we
talked about this a few days ago brought
up this point i mean this is absolutely
perfect
a genius strategy in order to get away
with these atrocities that clearly
people do not want people are sick of it
there's also two images going around the
internet right now that are going pretty
viral one is a southwest uh airplane
with the gaston flag outside of its
window and another one is someone in the
southwest uniform putting his head down
with a sign saying no jab no job why
question mark father of five 20 year
navy vet 4 000 hours south west airlines
and a heart that's broken so those two
images are going viral right now and
whether this was you know organized or
not i don't think it even matters at
this point because i think it's clear
with the mandates encroaching especially
on december 8th for many people all over
the world uh for many people in the
united states for many corporations that
these kind of um you know actions that
these kind of
disruptions are only going to get more
intense there's some people calling for
a national strike there's already
shortages at amtrak amtrak is already
cancelling a number of train options for
people uh because of you know issues
with their staff
you know again being extremely vague
here let's just call a spade a spade
here a lot of people aren't happy and
they're not stead and they're not
sitting down for it look why december
8th um i have no idea i think i
i mean we could speculate right now
there's no smoking gun evidence directly
saying why but it could be because it's
right before the holiday season it's
right during crunch time it's right when
everyone
is going to hope to have money to give
their loved ones gifts so that's some of
the speculation out there that wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait you're saying they
want the system to crash i believe there
is an element that will profit off of
the system crashing and they're making
protocols and restrictions and mandates
that will create a situation that will
put us there i do believe that
is somewhat done deliberately by the you
know special interests and powers that
do set to gain from hurting everyone
else i can't stand tradition man people
feel locked into this thanksgiving
christmas thing when you could be
celebrating with your family any time do
it now before the before the junkyard
people feel locked in people in cities
don't they have friends giving just like
they hang out i love that yeah but then
there are families that have
thanksgiving businesses like give people
time off on these certain days every
year so it's like you kind of have to
live your life around those days if
you're in that environment and that can
become very dangerous centralizing your
time is very dangerous well i'm not i'm
not a fan of the holidays because people
stop working yeah and then you know and
look the way the economy works is if
other people stop working i can't work
either yeah because there's only so much
so so on you know on holidays we
basically are just taking time off now
and i never i didn't i didn't used to do
this but it really is working on the
holidays like trying to lift 10 times
the weight you normally lift yeah
boeing also announced that all employees
quote must be vaccinated by december 8th
as well many other corporations are
doing this as well but this is all
because they're allegedly biden's
federal contractors uh and and this is
how again they're making it so just
weird with their uh mandates with their
quote alleged executive orders that that
it's very hard to follow a lot of this
it's not very simple i think it's meant
to confuse a lot of people it's meant to
scare people i think there's a big
agenda to make people fear to feel alone
to make them feel scared to make them
feel like resistance is futile when in
many instances it's not thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time